right now we have got the man of the
moment it is the final day of jeremy
corbyn's first conferences Labour leader
he is in Brighton the weather's been
marvelous there for for the conference
and indeed I think mr. Corbin for you
all week I think this may have been an
omen for you the Sun was shining it was
like a new dawn it was a lovely day
yesterday here in Brighton and it's a
lovely morning here absolutely glorious
morning and we've had the biggest
conference for years biggest increase in
membership still coming in where we are
a huge party on the March okay well that
was a good debt wasn't such a good night
for you last night because I know you're
an Arsenal supporter well not really
dwell on that but you know what score
all going so well then that happened
last night and I was wondering looking
at you yesterday every young lad has a
dream maybe of playing in the FA Cup
final and scoring the winning goal and I
was looking at you and on the love there
was for you in the room and what man
basking and all about it was yesterday
your FA Cup final it it was a great day
and but it wasn't a day that I spent my
life searching for I've spent my life
pursuing political causes representing
my community and working within the
Labour Party I was asked to and agreed
to contest the Labour leadership we ran
a huge campaign and got amazing levels
of support from a huge range of people
across the country and I was elected
leader I'm very honoured to take that
position and I will do my very best to
fulfill those hopes and desires and
dreams of the people that voted for me I
think my leadership is about including
people is about developing and extending
our party and above all putting forward
a political philosophy that challenges
the narrative that the poorest people
can achieve the best we don't have to
live in such an unequal society as we do
at the present time that's the message I
was putting across yesterday's rice it's
almost like a religious message or like
a religious leader in many ways and I
think even people who think I don't like
Lee but I don't like socialism there's
not a lot to argue you know they can
look at you in the saying oh and you
can't really argue with them about that
that all seems good however I put it to
you and I know you're into caring and
respect and I would love to
that but you know that doesn't happen on
TV so so anyway we'll do the next bit
which is why can't it happen on
television like well because people will
say I'm sucking up to you and I'm being
soft and we're giving you an easy time
so you know the way the game works so we
got to sort of change it people say see
people might say you alright look is a
bit hippie like you know that you sort
of want to hug everybody and the critics
will say yeah but there's no content to
what he said he was preaching to the
converted yesterday hardly react to
those who are going to say we want
detail we want detail look there's a
difference between respectful people on
a personal level and conducting politics
in an adult civilised and respectful way
but also I was pointing out some pretty
clear pretty stark facts about the way
the poorest in our society are treated
about the way our economy is very
unbalanced and about the need for
serious levels of investment in
infrastructure and manufacturing
industry so that we grow our economy I
said some pretty blunt things about the
way in which the government has decided
not to intervene to help the people on t
side over the future of their steelworks
I said some pretty blunt things about
the way in which so many people are
living in very poor quality housing with
no housing security whatsoever because
we have a government that is not
interested in regulating the private
rented sector or providing funds for the
development of council housing which
would actually be a good investment for
all of us sorry for interrupting but I
know you were saying lots of things but
I have to put another nasty question to
you were you saying your own things
front page of The Daily Telegraph new
politics old speech and you know do you
just take that on the chin and you say
it because I know of what was me and I
was in your position
month ago no one had heard of you little
responsibility little influence whatever
now you are the man right so if someone
handed me a speech I'd say thank you
very much and as long as I believed it I
would think I can deliver that so are
you going to sit taylors look that's the
way it was we went through a lot of me
and my team went through a lot of time
preparing this speech and working out
how to put across what is actually quite
a complicated message because you're at
one level speaking to a
wonderful conference here in Brighton
but clearly the speech is televised all
around this country and indeed all
around the world and so you've got to
make sure that people understand the
message that's being put forward the
speech was over 5000 words 350 words
were provided by a friend of mine I
liked the way he'd put them forward I
liked the words that he used so I used
them in my speech is that such a bad
thing I quoted poets I quoted Bennett
Correa coated Maya Angelou I quoted from
Pierre Hardy's works I tried to put
forward a speech that put forward both
policies and philosophy and message
about the attitude and way that I would
want politics to be conducted in this
country yeah everybody will like the
speech I'm sure you can't please all the
people all the time you can't and you're
gonna please very few people I suppose
that's the thing about politics and you
know what I'm trying to say is you know
you talk about you know a new year of
politics and respecting people and all
the rest and caring about people and but
you know what you don't love and respect
everybody why don't you just admit you
hit the Tories I mean you can't talk
about respecting love you actually hit
them know what I put forward was the
problems that people face in this
country and why I disagree with the
political philosophy being pursued by
the government and obviously by the
Conservative Party on the kind of
society they want to create in Britain
and what I think would be much better
which is a society where we recognize
the huge abilities and talents of
everybody particularly the poorest
people who are often locked out of the
possibility of achieving anything by low
wages by bad housing by insufficient
educational opportunities I want to
unlock the talent of everybody that is
the philosophy I was putting forward I
know
I know and you see all that signs
brilliant but if I was running a company
or you get chief executives listening
basically you're running a company
they're going to say look it's nice to
take into account what people have to
say but the way you put this across
everybody joined the party will listen
to all of you if you did really do that
you'd be too busy listening to ever do
anything so what it gonna happen is it
there is a democratic open process
within the Labor Party and all the
affiliates the Labour Party there is
huge talent all through that membership
we've got nearly four hundred thousand
members and growing very very fast but
at the mall in having their vote they're
interested in having their voice heard
they don't want the idea that there's be
some all-seeing all-knowing leader that
will decide everything yes at the end of
the day a policy decision will come
we'll come to that and we'll make an
agreement on aspects of housing policy
aspects of economic policy gear all
those things but surely at the start of
this process you set out what your
general philosophy is you set out how
you're going to be inclusive to all
people surely that's something that's
good about politics good about a
democratic society if it works and it's
like running a government doesn't like
to talk to you find time to see if it
but actually does work but you know it's
one thing listening to the party what if
you've got a disunited
party not even a disunited party at this
united cabinet because Parliament may
soon be asked to take a big decision on
further action in Syria are you happy to
lead a disunited party on that matter
from Hillary ban to Diane Abbott look I
was elected with over 250,000 votes of
party members and supporters I have a
huge mandate 60 percent of those that
voted voted for me to be the leader yes
there are people in the parliamentary
Labour Party who have a different
approach to the situation in Syria I
fully understand that there is a
possibility that the UN discussions
going on between President Putin and
President Obama and others will lead
some way towards a political solution
that's a good thing let's not preempt
whatever decision we may or may not
often
and there's a that you seem to be asking
if I may say so a slightly hypothetical
question no it's not it's never gonna
work isn't it look listen let's talk
football let's talk football right
you're a man's arson vanga my man was
Alex Ferguson even Louie vanghoul knife
do you think they go into the dressing
room and they say listen boys hi we're
gonna line up tonight what are we gonna
do tonight you disagree do you want to
play in gold do you want to play golf no
they don't forget always said he had to
make it clear there was one boss he was
the boss that was it
that's not your sort of way of doing
things though my way of doing things
because it's politics it's community its
people it's government is actually if I
may say so not the same as managing a
football it's always into a competition
if you want to be a winner
if you wanna be a winner guys I want to
win do you want to beat do you want to
be Prime Minister can you do you wanna
win the league come on please do you
want yes Labor's doing very well
groups laying for a pleasure awesome or
do you want to win of course I want to
win and of course labour wants to win
that's why people have joined this party
that's why this party's growing that's
why we are united honor desires for the
hopes of ordinary people in this country
that is what's so strong about this yes
there goes going to be some discussions
about some issues obviously every party
has to have discussions about some
issues and at the end of the day we'll
come to a conclusion yes the room for
people who have different views in this
party of course there are no one party
can have a monopoly of one single wisdom
with a mass membership but of course you
have to come to a conclusion and we will
mr. Corbyn you certainly are different
you are very very different it's
fascinating as a politician talking to
you and having an exchange with you with
that there is no Dyke and let me ask you
this this is my curiosity and I see you
today the way I normally recognize you
without a tie yesterday you were wearing
a tired conference delivering that
magnificent
each is it true someone lent you that
tie the tie came from a friend of mine
because some of my team didn't like the
color of the tie that I was suggesting
it was one of those rather odd
discussions we have I like to appear as
comfortably as I possibly can and I'm
happy like this but I was very happy I
hope I hope you will agree looking very
smart and tidy yesterday would you agree
with that I would agree with that I did
figure thank you I thought the red was
the right choice what color had you got
on before the red it was a different
shade of red X Oh different shade of red
okay well I thought it suited you I
don't think there's a huge political
debate here but there is no what tell
you there is because I do think image is
very important and although you were
preaching to the converted I think the
general populace if you bear with me on
this they want to know does he look like
a prime minister has he got the right
tie on and I know you did the thing with
the socks and the sandals or whatever
this week I know you want to project
yourself as something different but that
doesn't really a lot of people see their
prime minister in a different way that's
all I'm saying I understand what people
are looking for in a party in a
government in a future prime minister I
fully understand that I also think that
anyone however high and mighty they are
have got to remember from where they
come and got to understand how ordinary
people lead their lives and how ordinary
people come about conclusions to their
own lives and decisions and I live in a
normal place I live in a normal area and
I talk to an awful lot of people in my
community and many other communities and
I try to represent their ideas and their
views and look at the ways we can do
things differently and better in our
society